françois baroin a toujours des
expressions politiques assez violente
il devrait faire attention parce que les
maires de france ne sont pas forcément
sur cette ligne là alors bien sûr il va
être réélu président de l'association
des maires de france parce que le
système est tellement de cadenasser que
vous lui posez lui des quelque part ce
matin de faire attention
il devrait faire attention parce que je
crois que les français sont conscients
des difficultés de notre pays connaît et
ils ont le sentiment qu'il faut que la
france soit uni devant les difficultés
un peu une mise en garde que vous
prononcez ce matin non mais je trouve
qu'il y a mon prenons les les emplois
aidés dont vous venez de me parlait tout
à l'heure dans le programme de françois
fillon
il était écrit la suppression des onze
emplois aidés ce qui n'est pas si c'est
parce qu'il la volonté du président de
la république aujourd'hui
et donc quand on a entendu françois
baroin
enfin vraiment être avoir des propos
extrêmement fort et dur sur ce sujet on
a l'impression que les gens sont
complètement amnésique qui sont capables
de dire un jour quelque chose et le
contraire le lendemain
moi je n'aime pas cette politique je le
dis simplement et je ne connais bien
françois barois je crois qu'il aurait
intérêt à réviser un petit peu parfois
cette manière très violente et orthez de
toujours faire de la politique
politicienne